what you doing over there hiding this is
a good idea you have a bucket yeah
today we are going to be doing a
blindfolded taste test challenge I
parted with leis and they sent me four
of their new chip flavors and I'm going
to do a taste test but this isn't any
taste test jenna is here today we've got
a bucket full of ice water now I get one
wrong I get a cup dumped on my head I
was gonna lift it up and show it but I
promise there's the boss is really
having to heavy if I get more than two
wrong I get the whole bucket dumped on
my body oh wow I don't really want it
keep it away from me so for the flavors
we have the Greek to Z key the Szechuan
chicken the Tiki masala and the
Brazilian picanha cool okay yeah so no I
know what we're gonna do she knows what
we're gonna do okay I gotta be somewhere
every single what are these all the same
you know to be super well you're just
melting the chips how's this look good
Miffy
that's tight all right come on you're
never gonna guess I'm never gonna guess
what's this I haven't tried these yet so
I absolutely have no idea
yes I can see well okay not a little
smell all right the way I travel a lot
so I feel like I taste a lot of
different things now maybe my palate is
advanced all right we got ammo left
should I eat do you want to put it dry
chai ah let me try two
this is a great lunch hmm okay what is
it one I think it's it's the Greek one
wait let me show more I answered it
wasn't a big one double dipper kidney Oh
No what is it woman tell me what tell me
the brain time in a flavor okay I think
it's the it's gotta be the Greek - Zeki
Greek - Zeki is that your final answer
yeah I think it's Greek okay well you
were right yes okay next one the rule I
got it right
you're an idiot wait a minute was I
right yeah you are oh nice oh my head oh
my god your system
okay next time oh but you're so mean oh
my god
well since we're here we're gonna do the
next one
why would you even ready for this simple
tastes yeah simply delicious snack
Oh
I'm surprised look I think I know these
ones what is it I mean this is the UM
what is it I'm definitely the tikka
masala ha that's my final answer it had
like it tastes exactly like it I've got
good and bad news what good news is
you're right bad news you're a challenge
eater it's in my ear it's in my ear wait
I don't understand the rule of yet oh my
god
it's so cold it's so hair I promise I'll
my brother will I promise you're getting
your phone wet oh yeah ok ha ha
ok when all this is America you only
have two flavors left yeah well you
better not get him wrong I've got both
of them right oh I didn't understand the
rules ok we will eliminate maybe we'll
do a double flavor if you all know
what's gonna get what's gonna get oh
this is so close enough my idea and you
oh you're like ok we're gonna do the
last - ready - together - - ok Oh
okay this is crazy cuz like hey I think
this is the and this is the Szechuan
chicken no wait
give me another one it could be that it
could be that you hmm
put to taste she's really tasted some
chicken and then I taste some snake
they're a cheer all right all right I'm
not gonna cheat no oh okay all right
this is actually only one ship one chat
one fling okay give me one more so needy
get in there it's the Brazilian
brazilian Brazilian picanha the pecan oh
no bro oh it's so cold it's so cold oh
my god my body curling up feels like now
I really just nail so cold
you better wrong all right well I'm
gonna at least taste the last ones okay
what they were that which ones
we didn't do the chicken but only I know
my hands are all wet
okay - moms get me did you already tried
all of them I'm so cold
I'm learning thinking you know why what
the only reason that I think I got the
Greek one is because I remember looking
at the bag no you're so you're so I
thought about it again yeah oh come on
no no no no my fingers broken my hands
broken my hands broken man my hands
broken
so smoke home I'm so cold
like I actually want to cry I'm so
pretty single obey you guys always were
watching um thanks to leis for this
delicious treat that I just had a link
in the description for more info about
the delicious chips and Jenna I think I
broke my hand that was very mean of you
karma this is karma oh can you give me a
towel here we go bye guys
see you later
I have to turn my camera off but I can't
my hands are wet Wow
Lisa chase didn't get what yeah oh my
goodness
I'm sorry Z mm-hmm I feel good nice and
dry and fulfilled whoa
some things are happening some things
are happening okay this is great so now
I just gotta focus it